my understanding was that the
relationship between
the royal brothers was on a better track
and than it was when
harry left um i i think they became
closer
during the lockdown particularly when
the prince of wales was not well i was
told the boys were in regular touch on
the phone
we don't know whether they've spoken in
light of this serialization and the many
many headlines that it has generated
but i think it's safe to say that this
has done the relationship
no help at all i do know that the royal
family's concern about this book was
always that it was going to
open up old wounds and i think it very
much has done that
just as they seem to have moved on from
mexico
and from all the damage of earlier on
this year
suddenly this book has has reopened a
pandora's box
and um you know it's just not going away
so i think this book
and all of the revelations in it won't
do anything to help
um the brothers relationship which was
on the road to repair
i don't think the relationship was ever
back on track or as it once was
that things were getting better one can
only imagine that these devastating
headlines
um alleging that kate wasn't welcoming
enough
they didn't roll out the red carpet that
william was snobbish towards megan
that's not going to help a
reconciliation between the royal princes
the book claims that this was very much
a whirlwind
romance that pretty much after two days
at solo house harry knew that megan was
the one and there was something special
about megan and as the authors in
finding freedom put it
that she pretty much ticked every box
harry was almost
obsessed with megan and megan telling
friends that she couldn't think about
anything
other than harry which i think
gives some um credence to
to william's concerns that the
relationship was moving very quickly
um and you know harry obviously took
great offense when
william took him aside and and told him
to just make sure he was
he was sure and things weren't moving
too quickly but he wasn't blinded by
lust
there's no doubt about it that this
relationship was was
passionate and immediate and obviously
that
that was of concern to some members of
the royal family that
pat harry was rushing into something his
head had been completely turned
by this girl as william referred to her
in finding freedom one of the themes
that seems to be recurrent
is that harry felt very much like a
spare wheel
while the media loved this idea of a
royal
threesome kate william and harry
at points i heard him complaining that
he felt like the gooseberry you know the
third one along
at the date he never quite fitted in and
i think
while kate and william went out of their
way to make sure
harry felt part of this team part of
this trio everything from where they
lived
um you know a stone's throw across the
courtyard at kensington palace
to a royal foundation what that was the
three of theirs
they tried very much to include him
harry always wanted to be
his own person and i think megan has
been the catalyst which has enabled
harry to break free from
william and kate and that trio which was
at times cozy and convenient
but actually wasn't really what harry
wanted harry's
a very very focused man he has very
clear idea of what he wants to do
and that wasn't to be a spare wheel to
william and kate
he wanted to be his own person and i
think megan really gave him the
confidence
to break free one of the things that
that is explored at length in the book
is the palace politics
and it's it's very clear
that there are moments when the
households are
pitched against each other i think it is
fair to say that there is
competition between the households i'm
not sure it's quite as cutthroat
um as perhaps some of the sensationalist
stories might suggest
and but it is absolutely the case
that the palisades are out to represent
and protect
the principles who they are employed to
look after and by that very nature
you breed a competitiveness between the
palaces i mean the idea was that there
would be
one communications team at buckingham
palace to represent all members of the
royal family
that was quite simply never going to
work william wanted his own court which
he set up at kensington palace charles
has always had his own court
at clarence house and one of the
interesting things to come out of
of the new biography is that megan and
harry wanted their own court
at windsor and they were told that
couldn't happen it had to be under the
umbrella of the queen's communications
team at buckingham palace and for them
that was a big disappointment because
they didn't feel that they had the
autonomy
and the fallout as such was that they
felt that
courtiers at buckingham palace didn't
necessarily always have their best
interests at heart and there were a lot
of politics
at play these were cautious that the
couple apparently referred to as vipers
and i think in that respect you know
harry and megan clearly felt that they
were up against the palace machine
that the prince late princess of wales
also complained
um was was working against her for diana
they were the
the palace men in grey seats for megan
and harry they are
the vipers who they felt were against
megan from the start
clearly the way the couple handled their
departure from the firm
caused a lot of damage and that is
something that
finding freedom explores and i don't
think it was a secret
it was no secret that the queen the
senior members of the royal family were
were disappointed but deeply hurt by how
harry and megan chose to launch their
departure from the royal family
but i think the family had moved on from
that i think after the sandringham
summit which was the first time william
and harry
came together and having had a period
where they weren't even speaking
together
you know there was an acceptance that
this was what was going to happen
harry and meghan were going to start
their new lives and i think
that they were on a path to moving on
the problem with this book is that it
has busted open
that old and still raw wound
um at a time when it was just beginning
to heal
if diana was here she would be
devastated to see her two sons who were
once so close
fall out um so spectacularly i think
one of the things that has really struck
me in the reading of these excerpts
is the sadness that these two brothers
who were once inseparable
are now barely talking to each other and
i think if diana was still here
she would get them together knock their
heads together and tell them to sort it
out
[Music]